the really crazy after effect of the
banning or the rather the suspension of
Donald Trump's majority Muslim country
immigration ban has been the way that
Donald Trump has responded and this goes
to this concept of tyranny this goes to
the concept of autocracy and this
implicit understanding that Donald Trump
seems to have which is false that he's
just the CEO of the US and what he says
goes and I'm going to start by reminding
you that indeed Judge James Robart
suspended on Friday I believe it was the
Trump immigration ban that was appealed
by the Trump administration but it was
upheld the ban was continued to be the
band continued to be stayed by an
appeals court at the federal level and
Donald Trump again instead of trying to
defend the order on its merits chose to
do what many of us expect Donald Trump
to do now which is he decided to attack
Judge James Robarts starting with one
tweet where Donald Trump referred to the
judge as a so-called judge saying quote
the opinion of this so-called judge
which essentially takes law enforcement
away from our country that makes
absolutely no sense is ridiculous and
will be overturned this is an attack on
the very fabric of our democracy checks
and balances Trump is an absolute
disgrace if anyone's title is so-called
it's Trump who could rightly be called
the so-called president given that he
lost the popular vote by nearly three
million had Russia hacking in order to
help him defeat Hillary Clinton if
anybody here is only so-called in their
position it's Donald Trump judge Robart
was appointed by a Republican president
george w bush was confirmed ninety nine
to zero vote or didn't vote for trump
ninety nine percent of the senate voted
for judge Robart this is total and utter
contempt contempt for the judicial
branch of government
it's antithetical to everything that
they
State stands for and it's not surprising
because Donald Trump has questioned the
legitimacy of judges in the past
remember judge curial from Indiana
Donald Trump slammed him because his
parents are Mexican so he couldn't
possibly be an actual fair arbiter of
the law but then Donald Trump went even
further in a way that's just flat-out
dangerous to national security Donald
Trump sent out another tweet where he
said quote just cannot believe a judge
would put our country in such peril if
something happens referring of course to
terrorist attacks
if something happens blame him and court
system people pouring in bad this is so
dangerous
this judged like all judges this judge
is there to espouse what they believe
the law to be period blame the judge and
again this is a huge enticement to Isis
Trump is basically saying to Isis to
whatever group is trying to or would
like to do harm to the United States and
to Americans Trump is basically saying
hey if you attack us now it will send
our judicial system into disarray
because I've said I would blame the
judge this man is a systemic danger to
the United States
I can imagine asking I can imagine
Trump asking hey could I fire the judge
and the Constitution having to be
explained to Trump yet again this is
what people don't get Trump has been
doing this his whole life he's just
never been held accountable because it's
been his businesses there are actually
judges now and others who fortunately
are willing to put their feet down and
say hey you're not above the law at
least not completely in many ways Trump
has already been above the law but Trump
has not experienced this before and this
disdain for the judicial system is a
major red flag here and incredibly
dangerous you would think that the
right-wingers who call themselves
constitutionalist the constitutional
fetishists that I've been talking about
for many years they should be up in arms
about this few of them are most of them
are
silent